cash up you read it Benton read cash up
in your sexy voice this is my sex
operator voice it's the cash this show
is brought to you in the cash it's the
number one fine cash app it's the
simplest way to send and receive money
especially when I were your friends when
you owe your friends an apology for that
voice how do you use cash up
why use of the day to pay Mary from yes
in them
I usually the day to pay my friend for
all the martinis she bought me I love a
good teeny extra dirty three olives
platform teenies so your Samantha yeah
well yeah I ever think you're like man
I'm definitely not I'm definitely a
Miranda it's the easiest way to try and
grow your money in the stock market with
their investing feature with cash up you
can instantly invest in any stock as
little as one dollar you know this did
you know brokerage services are provided
by cash have investing a subsidiary of
square and member SLP see well now you
do as always when you sign it for cash
admin use the promo code Whitney not
only will you instantly receive $10 but
cash Apple also donate $10 to the trevor
project an amazing organization that
provides for executive services to
ventas across america all of me don't
forget the promo go in there when you
download the cash app from the app store
today
[Music]
what a crazy fucking combo yeah came
together
this is wild well I think you were
booked first so thank you for squeezing
me in let's start with you Jim you were
one of my favorite comedians before I
started comedy thank you still are thank
you that's not gonna go south and you
were always so fucking nice to me when I
started oh good didn't have to be at all
yeah it's funny like you look back I'm
really glad I was nice to comments cuz
everyone I was nice to has stepped over
Ben my god it was nice to Amy and Kevin
hard Britney but yeah I mean look
comedians always treated me well and I
will you never forget who treated you
badly like the guys who I love I've
loved for 30 years and they took good
care of me when I started comedians are
the ones who took care of me so I always
tried to be nicer to younger comics
because I don't know people were good to
me I love that you never you never tried
to fuck me which is actually kind of
insulting at this first start like when
comedians are very nice to you or like
hell you like help me get spots you like
help me get a teat my first TV spot I
think like big one on HBO and I'm
murmuring I guess I'm gonna have to suck
this guy's dick and I show up and you're
just like thanks for being here and I
was like nothing like you know I
actually was trying to fuck Artie Lange
another episode that was my goal the
whole thing was the fuck Artie so no I
remember Artie was in the basement
running his set with a discman like what
disk man with this unit and had the
headphones on and I remember that night
so vividly yeah down and dirty which
were you on the one with that was
already the headline of the would when
you're on ok yes yes I was so fucking
nervous and I spent the whole day trying
to find the right comedy shirt to wear
for my HBO appearance and you know it's
just like running around from store to
store I had no money I like $200 I was
like I have to get the right shirt as if
anyone gives a shit and I got a dumb
little see-through shirt with little
black dots on it and it was very ugly no
but you were funny you look good and
you're very funny I mean that was if
those are really fun stories or some
great acts that came through there
Jazlyn came through there right that's
right I mean the headline is the four
headlines were
was one episode Artie was one Patrice
was one and bill burr yeah and I was
just so grateful because yeah when I
started I was definitely kind of like a
edgier comic and everyone was shaming me
about it and then to be able to do this
show when everyone was kind of
celebrating and it was like a you know I
meant a lot to me well thank you and you
were great I love you well I love you
too
I'll see it sorry okay I never watch the
final cut either I just I heard you
killed by I don't and how did we meet I
know but I'm quizzing you I just want to
prove we were real friends not Hollywood
fake friends who see her right yeah
years like how many years ago with that
yes you were playing piano I was playing
the piano I want to say I don't remember
the night we met sorry I was I playing
my video so I'm glad you forgot okay
yeah I I'm sure I was playing the piano
at some point that's what I used to do
yes and I just remember becoming fast
friends
very fast friends very good friends and
you know my name now were you doing an
act or just playing piano are you
singing or were you drive is
accompanying accompanying SIA I used to
be a classical pianist when I was a
little kid and then I went and did the
music directing accompanying thing and
toured with musicians and I toured with
SIA for a while and that was my last
music kick before I started writing on
transparent no big deal thank and I want
to get to all that and get into a bunch
of stuff I just want to say one thing
about Jim that you will never remember
of one of the first times I was around
you we were at some Hollywood party I
want to say it was like Jeff Ross's
roasts show or some shit like this this
must have been 12 years ago and I was
kind of standing next to you and I was
so nervous to talk to you and you were
having a moment like you just got the
HBO show and you're just Opie and
Anthony was just popping like you were
just like in a big moment and you didn't
come out from New York that often and
this slimy agent kind of came up to you
sort of slimy fucking agent guy and you
just say agent came up to you and you
could you feel those fucking snakes
they're like barracudas like they're
circling and they're just
for their moment to come in and talk to
you came up to you're like hey Jim
what's up man
he looked up in the face and went where
were you 10 years ago really Wow good
for me I don't remember that and good
for me that I had balls for once in my
life that's what happens everyone wants
you after you've already been good for
10 years yeah you know they do and I
remember walking away from that going
okay once you get good you'll make it 10
years after that yeah it's a long road
it's always like I mean anybody who's
good who's doing the right thing I think
it's at least 10 or 15 years in before
people really know you I mean Kevin
harbors what ten years in before he
started getting yeah famous Fame you
know people think I he looks young him
reasons mid-thirties yeah totally and I
just remember going like it's okay if
they don't know fifteen years after
you're actually good that it may burn
nobody owes you anything
don't be entitled to success before you
like once you're ready 15 years later
they'll give a shit about you yeah and
it like really helped me with my
timeline of stop trying like trying so
hard to make it right you know which is
why everyone has to have so much plastic
surgery have something to say you'll
still be relevant 20 year olds 15 years
later exactly you're look incredible I
think you and Craig you're not wrong are
you happy with it you're happy with the
surgery toilet I am what surgery like
many surgeries at this point I met you I
mean preed with money I only had my
titties hanging out and you would be
squeezing them and you selling me a
moment of self-hatred
i had scar tissue built up but i was
trying to massage out i've had them
replaced
since then thank you and so do you feel
comfortable talking about them yeah sure
all of it wait just hold disclosure like
um don't go up to a trans person and
anything Whitney's about to ask me
because we've been friends for a long
time I asked you about bottom surgery
that's what you cannot ask about any
surgery no surgeries I'm gonna say
something we're gonna have a very
enlightening educational fun
conversation for the next couple hours
but I do we do need to be very clear the
comfort level
you're about to see is not something you
should have with the trans person in
public don't go up to a beautiful trans
woman and say how many searches have you
had see that scar absolutely not do
people that I'm an open book
people do that all the time yeah well
they they always asked me did you go the
whole way are you finished
are you complete and no I mean are we
ever complete you know that's the thing
it's like it's all the journey and
everyone's transition means something
different to them but they always mean
did you get a vagina did you have bottom
surgery okay I want to I want to back up
because we're gonna ask a ton of
questions and the point of this is to be
able to ask a ton of these questions so
somebody listening who is either Watson
Oh answer these questions too
embarrassed to ask might not understand
embarrassed to be wrong and have this
conversation so people understand a
little bit more but yes again disclaimer
do not ask any these questions to person
that you don't know or maybe one that
you actually do know we have a very high
comfort level and I know that you're not
gonna be uncomfortable because you can
correct me you can tell me I'm being
ridiculous
and I'm not gonna be embarrassed I'm a
nice a lot of really dumb questions
great that I may or may not know the
answer to and just because I think a lot
of people are embarrassed to ask and
they don't want to be wrong sure you
know and you know there's a there's a
time and place to learn these things and
I feel like a frank conversation on the
podcast is the way to go yeah with like
levity and humor and no one's getting
defensive because I see so many people
who are so gosh I just can't get these
fucking pronouns right and it's like
it's more stuff about them feeling like
they're failing or being embarrassed
right you know yeah people just don't
like being wrong yeah yeah and the the
pronouns are difficult and a lot of
times when people get them wrong they
feel like they're gonna get murdered for
getting them wrong and it's like and you
can't legislate people people should
just do it because they want to do it
and it's the nice thing to do and it's
the proper thing to do sorry it's not
it's very tricky for people and you know
and I've been around a lot of trans too
but it's still difficult I did am this
sort of like roundtable conversation and
we were going around our pronouns and I
got scared to do mine I just panicked
she yeah I was hurt she hurts
like I just was like with that right
like I was so afraid of fucking up you
know no I think I know my own pronouns
but you're just going around and you're
on the spot and and so everybody clams
up and they're so afraid that they're
gonna get cancelled or get in trouble
and it's just like if you get it wrong
just if you get it wrong it's all about
intention really you know it's a lot of
people will miss gender someone
intentionally
and you know I think that's what we're
trying to stop and I know that's what
we're trying to stop you know someone
who recognizes that I'm trans might come
up to me and you know and purposefully
say he or him and that's the hate that
we're trying to stop everything else you
know fuck up yes okay and you can sort
of feel the motive of like okay I know
you're trying to get this right yeah you
know if someone's heart is in the right
place no one is trying to my favorite is
when someone just stutters pronoun with
me I'm like oh honey it's okay it's okay
I'm not gonna call you out on Twitter
yeah but I think that I think that you
know people getting to know you better
is so helpful because I fucked up around
you before and you're just liked it I
think no I don't think you're like a
snitch who's like trying to catch
someone fucking up you know it's like I
think a lot of people have this idea you
know and it becomes this like
narcissistic self-loathing where it's
like people are gonna come for me if I
get something wrong no no everyone has
better things to do
yeah you know but there are times people
like to come for you to like let's be
honest if you fuck up people do enjoy
the pylon yes yes well that is true
especially if you're a public figure
they love it and even if they know you
didn't mean it it doesn't matter I mean
when the villages are burning somebody
sometimes it's kind of just fun to watch
the person get burned absolutely you
don't want to step in oh you see there
is some kind of primordial you know
reptile brain of when someone fucks up
and you're just like you know glomming
on and there's some sort of like when we
were in tribes that was a shaming like a
mass shaming or how everybody learned
what the rules were
now you're refreshing on Twitter just to
watch that them climb in the trends I
hope it gets to number one I hope it
gets to number one dark is part of our
fucking nature yeah get them it's ugly
yeah but we don't acknowledge it either
that's the funny part it's like we just
kind of we all act like well you know
there's those cancer culture but we
cancer culture exists because we all in
enjoy watching people get canceled so
true it's not just the people doing the
canceling it's all the other people just
kind of standing around going oh it's
terrible yeah and then when you drive by
a car accident you're like I hope I see
a dead person you're like primal brain
you're like and then when no one's dead
you're like bummer you're disappointed
if you don't see some real carnage yes
the little things that keep life
exciting you know all right so I don't
really know where to start so we're just
gonna start so you and I met where were
you
I haven't I actually have no idea
transit only my transition yeah trying
to make money yeah a lot of people might
not understand I'm just gonna start here
is that oftentimes people don't have
can't afford to ya know I have to do a
lot of these procedures
I couldn't afford anything I was living
in New York so I started my physical
transition around 2005-2006
um I'm not as young as I look and back
then I was in my late 20s I couldn't
afford anything I was this weird little
singer songwriter pianist in New York
City and so I held a concert called boob
aid and all these amazing artists in New
York came together to help me get my
boobs and Dolly Parton was one of them
who contributed some things that we
auctioned off so anybody I go on YouTube
and look her up singing Dolly Parton it
will fix your life oh thank you
I love dolly so I named this one Jolene
introduce dolly and without even
blinking or will take your math well I
got a well she introduced me to her
boobs
her name's shock-and-awe she has a
George W Bush joke era era joke about
her tattoos all over - that she doesn't
show he has she just started talking
about them actually that's where's the
gloves no I think the tattoos are to
cover scars she said oh wow just when
you can't love Dolly Parton more she's
amazed some shit like that so the
community came together to help me get
my your be top surgery because a lot of
people don't understand like to
transition costs a lot of money yes
we'll get into that and some insurance
is covering it but most insurances don't
cover um a lot of insurances are
starting to cover bottom surgery because
a lot of
sis people that means cisgender you are
cisgender you are cisgender a lot of sis
people assume that you know when you're
transitioning you just want to get a
vagina and that's all you want yeah um
but you know I don't know how you would
feel if you just had a vagina but the
rest of you appeared male right right
it's not really complete right a lot of
people so I started with with my top
surgery and then and then I put a pin in
everything and just focused on my career
because I realized that if I were to
afford anything else I actually had to
have some money not only dad it's
time-consuming the surgeries the healing
the you know it's yeah really a
full-time job it really is yeah where
were you when I needed my ice packs and
not all girls were bottom surgery either
no absolutely that's not all girls want
everything done and now I have not had
bottom surgery I rarely talk about that
except when I'm I did talk about my
penis in the New York Times once it is
not something that I want right now it's
not something I had some health issues
come up where I couldn't actually have
the surgery and so I made peace with you
know having I don't I don't even my
ex-boyfriend you know my ex
caught it machinist my ladies stick so I
was perfectly happy with having a lady
stick and I made peace with it and I
actually love my lady stick and I love
that that's part of me and that's part
of my transness and it doesn't make me
any less part of the female tribe yes
but so the bottom surgery is not the
ultimate goal for everyone but I also
think that's that's something that I
think a lot of people's brain explodes
because they're like okay I'm getting to
know this trans person their journey
wait you're gonna tell me other trans
people do it other ways yeah I know that
then all dudes say there's no there's
differences within people the transition
okay now I'm really lost I feel like
we're caught up on that yeah a bit
Society yes not where it was yes five
ten years ago they transitions can go
different ways they can go more FEM less
them and them for non-binary folks in
this spectrum as well I don't support
just becoming aware that knows and well
they don't always have to look the way
you have the picture in your head of
what right someone should look like no I
think that's like you know such an
important and there's different
transitioning within the community and
in terms of the sir
juries in the costs like I just think
it's so important that people understand
like this is this is not a for people
that really don't get it
this isn't just like a willy nilly this
is no I've spent probably a hundred
thousand dollars in surgeries in the
last five years alone since we've known
each other yes yeah okay a lot of them
should have been covered by a health
health insurance I mean some of them are
cosmetic for sure I own up to that
but most of them were just undoing the
effects of testosterone during puberty
so like taking away the bone is the main
thing that testosterone produces when
you go through the forehead bone just
saying this phone this phone this yeah
yeah this right you know you can't take
away my height all right right
what's gonna have that done babe really
expensive very painful and and what how
do you decide the order in which you're
gonna do them just whatever you're
comfortable with I I was really tired of
being called out for being visibly trans
in public so my face meant a lot to me
because that's the thing people see um
and it worked I don't I don't get called
out as much anymore it's not just about
that though it's how would I imagine
myself alone on a deserted island
somewhere you know and it's fucking
beautiful that's how I'd imagine myself
just the way I am and so Jim with you
being in relationships with trans women
when did you first start talking about
this publicly probably 2003 my
generation is all different like you
know I'm when you and you you're a kid
it was just it wasn't acceptable you
just you know you were fucking gay you
know
so I'd say 2003 I did a show called
confessing it in Montreal that Jeff oh
my god like I was named Jesus Jeff left
on him Jeff Dunham yes it was me him in
the puppet we all opened up in the park
I forgive me Jeff I know you for many
years my memory is going but it was
called confessing you told a story
publicly that you'd never told so I
always do I love trans girls but I wound
up having sex with this girl I picked
her up she was I was driving back to New
Jersey and she asked me for a ride and I
was again we were flirty and we kind of
got a law
and you know we hooked up and like we
had sex in my car and I told that story
but I kind of lied a little bit I was
just kind of getting into publicly
disgusting
and I was like a little scared of how to
say it so I had to I lied about well I
think she was trans and I think then at
the end I saw a dick because the fucking
lies I knew magic going down please oh
my fucking Daffy Duck an exploding cigar
you know it's like progressive the way
you talking about things you get more
comfortable as you get older and you get
more comfortable with who you are you
start talking about it more and more but
that was was it was the Montreal Comedy
Festival confessing it and then Opie of
the Opie and Anthony show we were kicked
off the air at the time and said I'm
gonna I'm gonna write down now I told
him a story called monster rain - about
ice to blow my friends and I was a kid
nobody said I'm gonna write those down
and we go back on the air I'm reminding
you of that shit any day became a name
my HBO special monster rain but the
trans stuff I talked about kind of from
that point on but it was it was kind of
harder to get into and you get more and
more comfortable every layer you peel of
yourself on stage you get more and more
comfortable would you say in the
beginning there was like an
embarrassment there a shame of just like
what are people gonna say and it's not
knowing yourself yeah it's also not
knowing itself but self identifying with
guys like guys who like trans women it's
almost like it's about
self-identification like if I was gay I
would have come out many years ago I was
gay for years almost I was gay but then
I'm like I don't think I am because I do
love women but you can't you also I
don't think if you're dating trans women
and and if you if you're a man you like
dick you're not straight yeah so this is
this illusion that men have like no I'm
totally straight no you're not and it's
okay to not but don't don't try to
change the label to make it palatable
and comfortable and fit a narrative that
is our people are happy with so that
that's the hard part it's about self
identifying a lot of men that I've dated
who love dick do identify a straight man
who love dick though yeah you know or
straight men who love to get fucked yeah
everyone knows that pegging is a thing
yeah yeah have you ever been on the
Internet yeah and I've been on Reddit
how do you identify
you know I get it's got to be bisexual I
mean I mean by process of elimination
it can't be straight are you attracted
to men not attracted to men as far as
being male I don't like maleness at all
I despise male energy it doesn't turn me
on meat at all I don't like and then so
did you feel like being a comedian it's
there in a weird way there's almost an
ease your way to kind of like you know
say cuz you can say it on stage and test
it out it's kind of a joke first and see
how it goes right then again comedians
are can be kind of a tough scary crowd
of people like do you think being a
comedian
helped you be able to come to this
realization sooner or later well sure I
mean because I can talk about that my
job it's kind of hard for an accountant
to walk into his job and go I couldn't
believe you should have seen that yeah
yeah you can't do that in that job right
in this job you can explore any angle of
it you want publicly um
and work through it my therapist told me
you got to stop working through it on
stage but I'm like that's the only I can
do it
is you talk through it and why why not I
don't know I don't know but I know that
you can't you just can't need people to
approve of it that's the problem you
have to be ready for them not to approve
of it like anybody in my life who
doesn't like it can get out of my life
and that's not arrogance it's just this
is who I am and if you're not
comfortable with that fine but leave and
the audience the audience is just so
fucking annoying too cuz I do a joke
about dating trans people and they're
like oh and then they realized oh he
means it and then they kind of come
along and it kind of annoys me like what
did you need that fucking that little
co-signature before you're okay to laugh
about something but if they sense that
you are not needing them they tend to
come along with you a little bit more
but my crowd is very male very
blue-collar yeah and they're very
they've never given me shit about it
like they don't they're they know it's
the truth they accept me for who I am
and they're fucking great have you had
people reach out to you and be like
thank you for talking about this now
many many yeah I get trans people but
also a lot of guys better like I get I
get emails all the time like man you
kind of made me feel more normal about
liking that aw right I like that or I
never talked about that before you know
so yeah I get that a lot from people
that's like I feel like the trans
tipping point happened with Laverne Cox
on
cover of Time magazine for women for
trans women trans men are still the
tipping point we're still working on I'm
getting the education and advocacy out
there with trans men up front and center
in the movement but even further behind
are the folks that are attracted to
trans folks every man that I've dated
has had incredible insecurities and
fears about being trans amorous um you
know a lot of them have worked through
some of them have worked there more than
others but there really are so few
spokespeople out there um yeah I just
it's just it's just is it weird I don't
know I mean we travel all over the
country like you know I meet so many
people like it's just it's so weird to
me that there's in Hollywood the place
that's supposed to be the most
progressive left there's just so much
shame within this well nobody wants to
lose privilege yes once you understand
privilege and once you sit in a place of
privilege it's very difficult to walk
away from that no matter who you are and
I think a lot of these men don't have to
sacrifice their privilege in order to
have a somewhat happy life you know if
you're fucking a trans woman but you're
gonna marry a syst woman why do you need
to why do people need to know that about
you I think that's what's going through
their head is that they're gonna lose
that privilege if they keep that person
in the closet they can compartmentalize
and they can move on with their lives I
think eventually that probably is not
very healthy
I would imagine psychologically to be in
the closet like that but I I think it's
all about the fear of losing privilege
and that's why you see so many a-list
celebrities and and I mean business
folks and politicians who are having
these trans amorous relationships but
they're keeping us in the closet you
also it I think for a lot of guys is
deeper than that to where I don't even
know if you if you some guys might think
that I don't know if guys actually
equated to privilege it goes down to
like am i a fraud am i a liar like who
the fuck am i you don't know who you are
like that's a really it's a crazy thing
to go through life not knowing who you
are because you did you fight it you
know I mean because I forgot like when I
was a kid I and I blacked it I got
called a fag
a lot when I was a kid like you can't do
it now but in the 70s Aramis yeah yeah
I'm trying yeah I couldn't have sued
them for slander if they were right I
mean the way I was behaving there was
not a lot of that big you atiim but you
know it's like what this thing where
there's all this shame that comes with
it so it's fucking it's about
self-identification and it's about not
knowing who you are and it goes beyond I
think oh people are gonna walk away from
me it's like am i a fraud like I don't
know who I want to love women I don't
want to love I don't want dick I want
pussy but then you date a woman with a
vagina you're like fuck now I want the
other that's not what I want and it's
not I mean I would I would date a woman
I guess who and I'd say I don't like
saying cisgender I'm fuck I did it that
kind of drives me to Lane yeah I know
it's there stay but I don't need to
disguise it like if I'm dating somebody
and she has a dick I prefer that yeah
that's that's the reality of it that's
as blunt as I can be about it it's it's
not necessary but that's what I prefer
have you are you trying to hook us up
right now just some weird miracle
happened I think it's also the the
closet the being in the closet happens
because for so many years trans women
were seen as these deceptive folks we
were seen in Hollywood it tricky tricky
trickster do something your hair is a
different color today than it was
yesterday yeah that's just woman a woman
everyone thinks you're tricky everyone
thinks you're lying I'm just trying to
survive I'm starting to be happy and I
think to be seen in public or to admit
that you you are dating someone who's
very misunderstood by society is another
reason why people stay in the closet and
so give me an example of I mean in your
life when you're dating men that I mean
do you feel right away like oh I'm being
kept a secret or I mean they're they're
not right away I think there's a lot of
denial that happens depending on how hot
the person is so if you know if I'm
talking like they're really hot like
I've never met a your friend
they come to my house after 10 p.m.
wait a minute but no I that did happen
yet no that happened once I was with the
guy for 6 months and like never met one
of his friends and then finally we were
out in public and holding hands and he
dropped my hands when he saw someone and
the person asked him how he how he he
knew me and he goes oh we work together
it's like ok oh that's awful that's not
okay I still stayed with him for three
weeks three weeks of solid fighting but
it was like what what happened with that
because you know everyone wants to be
loved and nobody wants love to go away
and I did feel loved in those private
times and I'm talking this happens like
three years ago this is not when I was a
teenager you know so this is something
that like trans women of all ages go
through and I finally that was the last
I had of that I mean I can never date
anyone who's in the closet again do you
have the conversation up front with
someone when you first start seeing them
like hell yeah you always meet in public
always meet in a restaurant first of all
that for a first date for a first day
that knocks most the guys out who you
meet online because they want to or I've
gotten messages when I'm in the
restaurant I'll get a message saying hey
I'm in the parking lot can you come out
here like no I'm not going out to the
parking lot
they're so terrified to be seen in
public with the trans person especially
someone who is visibly trans it's easier
to spot women now than it was 15 years
ago cuz everyone's talking about it
years ago like women who like wouldn't
quote unquote spotted now you keep this
in the zeitgeist everybody is aware of
it so it's like it's easier to tell now
that it was years ago because everybody
is so interested it's so there it's not
at all hard the one girl told me I have
the I came at me because I know I could
tell through the fucking Hubble
telescope but well yeah girl tell me you
have the eye you can but it's it's it's
now is everybody's so aware of it when
you're hyper layer so it's not and
that's why a lot of trans women are
getting more hate now more than ever I I
got the most hate when I was living in
New York City because people understood
and knew about trans women
so people clocked me more often where I
would go to my hometown in Pennsylvania
a little village of 200
and they're like way out she's wearing a
dress mice must be a woman that must be
a woman and meantime I have like stubble
on my face so I never got clocked there
but in New York I got caught a faggot
I've never been called a tranny in a
negative sense I've only been called a
tranny and a positive sense from my
sisters but in New York that was
happening and that was ten years ago and
I was there so now it's happening a lot
more all over the place where trans
women are getting called out for the
transness I'm facing a lot more hate and
a lot more violence than ever see that
is terrifying to me and also I think a
lot of people might find to be
surprising because I think ostensibly
we're going oh my god there's poses on
and winning every award and transparent
won every award and like you know there
seems to be some kind of extensible
progress but what you're saying is with
this new level of education people are
now able to identify more and it is
progress to have things out in the open
to be able to talk about things but if
we're only at the very beginning of that
progress there's still so much more
obviously so I just want to back up a
little bit to when you knew as a child
something was in a foot nothing was a
foot with me I know that something was
something with the village it was like
why is everyone acting crazy like why do
I have to do this and why do I have to
behave like this but when you were
playing Red Rover oh yeah I put that
into transparent it where that's right
there is I I was playing Red Rover with
the girls and suddenly one day I'll just
decided I must have been six they just
decided I couldn't come over and they
just didn't call me over and when I
finally tried to break the chain I just
couldn't break the chain and I was like
well what's wrong and then they said
well you're a boy you can't play with
this anymore
and so I burned down the school no but I
just stopped talking for almost two
years I didn't play with any kids I just
faced a brick wall at recess and I was
like well fuck fuck these kids fuck
everyone it wasn't something that I
thought was wrong with me ever it wasn't
until years later where I was beaten
so much where you have to learn to
behave this way and you have to learn to
say this thing and you have to speak in
a certain tone that I realized okay this
has something to do with my gender
mm-hmm and the rules of society
regarding my gender and so on my doll
life in my transition it hasn't really
even been about the physical change it's
been about undoing all the programming
all the male programming like I was
taught from that age can I ask you if a
child in that situation today like what
would you have needed back then that you
didn't get besides all the bitches just
support and understanding the vocabulary
we didn't have the vocabulary my mom by
the way my family and I have come so
long so far yeah we get along so well my
parents are so supportive they go to
PFLAG now it was nice that way parents
and friends of lesbians and gays it's a
it's a little bit of an outdated term
but it's a group that they go
jessylvania vintage I'm a friend of a
gay weight parents depends of lesbians
and gays yeah so they go to groups and
you know and then they talk about their
feelings now and and we talk about how
things used to be
and one of the things that they said was
that they just wish they had the
vocabulary yeah the tools to be able to
identify what was happening and support
yeah they just had no idea they thought
I was rebelling because um I liked
glitter and piercings and I was
rebelling at one point the blue mohawk
okay that was rebellion I want to just
go through a couple things because as
we're talking there's certain things I'm
going you shouldn't say that you
shouldn't say that and why I remember
when we met we met we talked we
connected and then later something came
out about being transgender in the first
thing I thought was like I had no idea
and and I had no idea
you're not listening she was
transforming I did no I said I literally
was like and then I was like oh my god
should I tell her that she passed should
I be like hey I had no idea and there
was like I think you did actually it's
not really a compliment I mean some for
some people it's a compliment I think
I know that that's not something you
should say and can you just tell us why
but some people they'll say of how you
did a really good job I think a lot of
people okay i facilitated the surgeries
in a way that maybe fits in line with
what society deems to be beautiful but
yeah I'm proud to be trans and I think
to say something like that you're
assuming that person is not proud to be
trans or that person has shame around
their transness that's interesting or
you want to give yourself like points
sure something or you just think it
becomes about the SIS person which it
always does or you're just like so
excited for the person you know it's
just like just like a weird sort of
selfish need to let them know sure I
think you just saw I just wanted to talk
about surgery dhm detox where were you
when I needed you in my 20s dhm detox
this is a company that gives you
vitamins that will stop you from being
hungover after drinking this is a very
you product very type A personality
process because it's a pill you take
while you're drinking you have a couple
drinks a couple teenies in your case
simultaneous you take the pill while
you're drinking your tea knees to get
ahead of that hangover it's a plan B a
hangovers natural ingredients
antioxidants and vitamins that help
boost your body's natural response to
alcohol so that you do not have a
hangover the next day because I want to
get drunk but I also be healthy I want
to get drunk but I need to be functional
the next day you know like the worst is
when you're not dreaming cuz you're
worried you gonna have a hangover the
next day and be like a zombie you come
with some less than a burrito like don't
yell at me don't talk to me before I
have my coffee how important is your
next day very important for just a
couple dollars you can wake up feeling
fine after a long night drinking they
also have free shipping on all orders in
the u.s. dhm detox is a risk-free
purchase so if you're not satisfied
after taking the product they'll give
you your money back this is a no-brainer
Benton I got you 20% off your order to
just head over to dhf detox com use
promo code Whitney a checkout dhm detox
dot-com be a functional
this is it I don't take on just any
sponsors I'm not like these other
podcasters that just lifelessly read ads
for products they don't even use third
love this is a bra company and look at
me
wearing it showing her brow she's
showing her bra wearing it I'm the real
deal I'm authentic I don't lie to you
people okay third love we got it I wear
it I'm not full of bull crap I love that
bra I love this I did a great job
only bra where I swear to God because
this is what's so good about this
company
it comes in half sizes you know it's
what people don't understand I'm between
a C and a D my boobs aren't big out
there wide and if the big wide boob I
have a white boom I'm known from a wide
sloppy naturals is that a D is too big
and the underwire goes up into my armpit
and impales me and if it's too small it
squishes your boob and your boob looks
like a little nub but not this one your
boobs are laying on memory foam
mattresses these are it is memory foam
material so this bra remembers the shape
of your boob and like a good luck it's
got it I love this company you take a
quiz they send you the perfect bra they
have tons and tons of sizes third love
knows there's a perfect bra for everyone
so right now they're offering my
listeners 15% off your first order go
2/3 love.com slash Whitney to find your
perfect fitting bra I used to only wear
sports bras before this this is the
first underwear wire bra that I can
really wear I'm telling you and get 15%
off your first purchase
third love.com slash Whitney for 15% off
tada
[Music]
have this you know the ultimate tricking
guys to a lot of that yeah there are
girls who might do it but a lot of that
has men know and they don't like the
acknowledgment like it's almost like a
lot of guys want to pretend even in
their own head that they were fooled and
like all I didn't know that's a little
easier but I know one lone girl I know
she said she would meet guys and she
would always tell them through text
because she's like if you tell them in
person a lot of guys I mean deep down
they knew anyway but you might get a
very violent reaction so she said she'll
always text it to them so if they have a
bad reaction they don't have to feel
like they have to reaffirm where they
are by being shitty to her and he Herson
I do the same thing when I do the same
thing with my HIV disclosure I'm HIV
positive
I'm very open about that an activist in
that community i text both of those
things in person so if the person ever
like tries to pull some sort of stunts a
she didn't tell me she's trying to trick
me I'm like I have a screenshot and
people will try to do that they try to
what pretend they didn't know they try
to pretend they didn't know that they're
not attracted to trans folks you know or
they'll get so close to their desire and
then back away because the shame rebound
so they get so close and then suddenly
they'll freak out when I was a kid sorry
to Roger when I was a kid this this is
how that is when you get close if I
would masturbate when I was really
eating I was 12 or whatever I would
think about a girl or I'll think about a
boy but there was times where if I was
thinking about a boy as I was about to
orgasm I would make myself put a girl in
like it was really it was almost like I
would immediately change the slide just
so like I would pray afterwards yeah I
didn't go that far but I'm aggressive
but no I would you put that that slide
in so that was the final image I had so
I get why people do that cuz I did it
and I didn't know what I was doing like
I didn't realize that that's what I was
doing at the time there's a lot of
programming that we all carry with us
and a lot of shame and then do you
remember any specific programming like I
mean watching porn
like what like where did you get the
initial programming from the stuff
besides like the obvious phobic stuff
like Church will we say it's Church it's
porn Church I mean everywhere television
one
the reasons that I'm so passionate about
my job as a writer is that I get to put
characters on television that I had
never seen before and when you don't
have the reflection of who you are when
you're not able to relate to something
in the media which is that's our mirror
now that's our modern-day mirror there's
an absence and a sense of shame of like
why why can't I see myself there must be
something wrong with me because of that
and that is my point of like how we
can't point to something that caused
this because there's just an absence of
it
right and when there's just such a
dearth of it you have no word uh yeah
you just think you're crazy there are
certain points for sure that we can
point to in regards to the shame that
was spread I mean just from the 80s with
the fear of hiv/aids and the homophobia
that translated into transphobia as well
and then of course I mean every war
that's been about in the name of
religion as well yes yes yes yes that'll
do there are certain points but but most
of it is more insidious than that right
I'm gonna ask a couple very dumb
questions that I think a lot of people
want to pretend they know the answer to
but if you were actually to ask them
they might get ripped off just to really
get granular someone asked what is the
difference between transgender and
gender non-conforming some folks who are
trans also identify as gender
non-conforming I do some folks don't so
those two terms overlap trans is the
word that most people use now as a term
where there's a lot a lot of wiggle room
for self-identification within the term
trans gender non-conforming means that
you don't conform to the gender you were
assigned at birth so that makes sense so
simple but some trans folks do believe
that they can form to a gender if you're
a binary trans woman that means that you
do identify strongly with being a female
I identify mostly with being a female
part of it also people get afraid you
they're afraid of being people who if
they're really hesitate
is a fear of exposure like people are
failing you might say this wrong you're
gonna see how I really feel it's like if
you don't have anything to hide with how
you feel about it you're not gonna be
afraid to make me I wouldn't your friend
I'm a mistake like yeah we all say like
you can't who I am
yeah say are you afraid of saying the
wrong term or oh no I didn't say this so
I don't know like I don't know what
bindery not come on I really don't know
what a lot of that is yeah okay I don't
know what it is so what you if you're
not afraid of being exposed for having
shitty feelings then it's more
comfortable I think a lot of that
hesitation is people are afraid that
their true feelings yeah are gonna come
out with if there's an ugliness that
they feel that's gonna be exposed I mean
we'll see and I think that there's a
little bit right now of like the words
keep changing you know that's that's
what I hear a lot of people like I can't
keep up with all these terms you know
yeah and what words well someone does I
mean these are literally just from
Instagram questions I got I mean I do
understand like tranny used to be a good
thing in the 90s and in the early aughts
and in the sisterhood we used to call
each other that and then people started
using that word weapon as a weapon and
so we stopped using it most of us
stopped some of us still say in private
but it's not something you should say
now yeah I do understand and then you
know transsexual was the term as well I
always identified as I still identify as
a transsexual because that's um means
medically I have transitioned
transgender doesn't always necessarily
mean that there's a physical transition
happening right right and I also just
want to get into why this is so
important back to you not being able to
play Red Rover why it's such a big deal
to just learn and understand this like
you know I think about you know I
remember it's just the changing of the
driver's license the passport like just
can you talk a little bit about the
process of just having to go through all
the fucking legit lacks at all uh-huh
waking you up I'm waking you up and just
like the you know I know the word
microaggression you know people
sometimes roll their eyes at but the
word does mean something important yeah
I mean it's going to the DMV and then
when I moved to LA my New York ID said
but my passport still said mail and so I
went to the DMV ten years ago to get my
driver's license here and she just
looked at me and she goes honey that's
not gonna fly here and she just put in
mail I was like excuse me and she's like
we need a doctor's no and I'm assuming a
doctors in New York so and she just like
wouldn't even give me a chance and you
know two days later I brought her a
doctor's note like I had to bring in a
doctor's note to say that I'm female
even though my ID in New York said that
I'm female
so that person was just having a bad day
and obviously didn't like trans folks so
like little things like that would
happen here and there at the Social
Security Department I did try changing
my age actually and that did not fly but
they were fine with the gender I was
like honest 9.99 bored she'll be so
bedazzled by the gender change she
noticed and then I mean for someone who
is not in a situation who you know is on
the ward winning shows and getting all
the bags like what does that process
look like for someone that might not be
financially solvent yet in terms of it
can really be a nightmare it's expensive
there are a lot of court fees that you
have to pay just to change your name and
to change your gender and then you know
we were talking about the medical bills
as well on top of it but also seeing a
therapist a lot of people don't have
access to mental health care that was
certainly the most important part of my
transition has been mental healthcare it
all started with therapy and then it all
kind of blossomed from there or
unraveled if you will so there's that
and then also you just need all of these
letters yeah I had to get what surgery
was I having I don't remember I had some
surgery like a couple years ago where I
had to have two letters from different
doctors and on one of the forms it said
does this person act feminine and I was
just like really we're putting lots of
angeles two years ago do they act
feminine and i had to have a
professional check that box mark
boxing yes I had a good doctor actually
who I told her I wasn't gonna get the
second letter I was like I only have one
therapist so it's a psychological
evaluation in order to get a surgeon or
you get a surgery yeah so in order I'm
41 years old like you're born 1984 do
you need that I do my insurance to cover
it or for the surgery to have just to
have the surgery sorry I'm it's a lot of
letters I've had a lot of lever
logistics yeah okay and it's one of
these things once it's out of the way I
put it out of my mind right it's been a
nightmare and then I'll I'll go revisit
it if I'm gonna write about it all right
right so it's not something I carry with
me on a day-to-day basis because it's so
heavy and and a bit traumatizing right
and then and when I think a lot of
people you know might understand that
this sort of concentric circle of
transitioning and possible like if
someone someone for suffering from
addiction and you're having these
surgeries and you have to be on
painkillers to recover from the surgery
it's just also sort of the additional
struggle if someone you know is in
recovery or something what that brings
right
I love the pain get to have a free
laughs no I am in recovery I am sober
and I mean that's just a whole that's a
whole other element of things I thank
God you know I have people around me who
care about my sobriety and help me take
care of pain management mm-hm
and then and then in terms of I just
want to go back to this because I think
a lot of people have questions about it
and really do want to understand in
terms of the surgeries you prioritize a
lot of people can't afford to do
everything right which is why we're
fighting for recognition of the the
spectrum of gender for what it is I
think it's important just to release the
the stigma around being gender
non-conforming so that you can figure
self out first before you need to go
under the knife if you do go under the
knife and then everything just becomes a
lot easier I'm gonna point on yeah and
then in Hollywood how was your
experience ten years ago versus now I'm
gonna ask you this - well I just sold my
gender
you know I did it's fine it's going well
I ten years ago I moved here to make
music and I was doing ok I was doing
really well in New York before I
transition and then all my work dried up
which is why I moved from being a
pianist to being a singer-songwriter
pianist so that I could educate people
about what gender was through my music
through my lyrics through my live shows
and then actually when we started
hanging out I I was like oh Whitney's
really funny and we laugh a lot together
and I was like well maybe I'm a little
funny too because people would laugh at
my stories that I would tell in my shows
between songs so I started writing a
stand-up routine in 2000 so I was gonna
do stand-up for a minute and at that
moment I met Jill Soloway who said are
you a writer I'm looking for a writer
for transparent and so I had all of this
material and I'd put it into a short
story overnight and sent it to Jill and
then I was hired to be a staff writer on
transparent after a bit of training hmm
it long story short so you're now on
pose which is a show which if you
haven't seen it how dare you about ball
culture in New York why is that so
important
well it's the first show where every
trans role has been played by a trans
person and it not only features one
trans person but it's an entire cast of
trans folks and also it we focus on the
lives of trans women of color which is
something that we have not seen in the
media accurately portrayed and it it's
about the ball scene in the 1980s so
there's a lot of talk and education that
we're doing around hiv/aids as well and
it's just a lot of fun it's a lot of
people don't understand that pop culture
references ballroom culture yes in
everything that you see every pop star
that you're watching there are dance
moves that are happening they came from
ball culture does that frustrate you
when people don't know I mean sure it's
always frustrating but I get back to why
don't people know okay well they just
haven't been taught so how do I teach
them right you just that's so mature no
I thank you yeah yeah that's two comics
you're listening to ball culture of you
disgusting are immature not about
testing like when I see in like a
exercise class someone says something
from like recovery I'm like that's a
recovery thing is that yours like it
with me off you know like it's just like
like oh my god that's so genius it's
like dude that's a fucking AAA thing
exactly two years ago three nineteen
fifties out of the convention everyone
in spin class is like oh my god genius
said it makes me fucking angry it used
to make me really angry but that I
realized that I was holding me back I
was getting so caught up in my
resentment that I I wasn't actually
doing anything about it my life but once
I released the resentment I realized oh
I can do something about it and my whole
career unfolded because of that heard my
mercury expanded because of that and I
was able to find my voice as a writer
because I was able to listen to what
people needed there's also just this
thing and I'm thinking about you Jim
because it's like I you know you're
stand-up I mean granted I mean you're
just one of the best thank you and I
just feel like you fucking on you're
just firing on all cylinders right now
do you think that talking about this
like unlocked another level sort of in
terms of your you know being able to
write as a comedian and be truthful
yeah just frees you up because I just go
on and talk about well you know that's
all it does it frees you up a little bit
um I don't know if it makes the writing
any easier just it's more easy it's
easier to be honest and not have to
worry like how do I say this without
actually saying that part like you know
I can just say whatever I want
yeah so yeah it opened you up in second
in the also life if it's if it's a
secret it's harder to dance around it
and if you're talking about it
truthfully it's it's much easier to plow
through it yeah people are very
responsive to again if they know that
you don't need their approval
yeah tend to stick around yeah that's so
interesting yeah yeah it's just like I
do feel like as a comedian if you have
secrets it's like you're gonna plateau
yeah I mean sometimes the secrets will
will drive you to but if you if it's
something that you're really trying to
avoid it's gonna make your writing it's
like literally this giant thing in the
room that you're walking
in writing it's difficult to do that
like I don't know how to talk about
dating if something is gonna come up
about dating if that if it ties in with
the person's trans I kinda have to say
it it doesn't have to be all about that
either but that's not all my dating life
is and that's not all you know if you're
even if you're with somebody who's trans
it's not just like you know we're out
[Laughter]
open and stuff like that I was with a
girl and uh and she was you know she was
you know someone who was not afraid of
confrontation let's just say but we were
holding hands walking on this was uh on
the side of Manhattan and she was a she
and she was a group of guys let go of my
hand like which I realize she was
probably much hotter I was playing like
way below her fucking level she was
always like that's just easier some like
it was almost like she sense maybe there
would be a problem you know I mean
there's not even everyone your friends
came up no doubt about but remember
we're walking just one upgrade she just
wanted to leave the optional she was
afraid it could get like somebody could
say something like she was aware that
these people might say something and
like not in the street and not know you
know like she was a little bit paranoid
about it - was that recently that's
probably the last two summers Wow it was
yeah it was on if I was I think it was a
July 4th actually we were going from
dinner to my house I think but it was in
the summer so we were walking and she
you know she I guess I've had so many
people say things to her that she was a
little worried that it was gonna get
weird yeah for me
yeah point you know people are really
surprised to hear these stories but they
happen all the time for trans folks an
ex of mine I was walking holding hands
was downtown and someone just came up to
him and said hey you know that's a man
like right in front of me like Ryan to
me as if I weren't there and luckily he
was so shocked that he didn't do
anything about it otherwise I think it
would have gotten violent afterwards he
certainly was so route up and it's
annoying too because it's like what's
the motive of the guy doing it like what
do you think you're doing yeah like if
you're that driven to walk
her and say something you have some
investment in it yeah you have some
fucking stake in mentally if you care
that much to get like out of your way go
out of your way or to care yeah right
you know I mean if it's like the fact
that it matters to you at all do you go
to places like like I always wanted to
go to Dubai but then the older I get and
the more I realize like that whole
fucking part of the world it's just
really shitty and transphobic and fuck
them so I kind of don't want to go it's
illegal is it illegal to go even if it
says female on your George Chiti
gorgeous was just turned away was it for
that reason or was she oh okay being
trans so what countries is it all of the
Emirates I'm guessing by Islam thinking
I actually don't know what what
countries I just know to buy yeah I know
in Iran they will pay for your entire
transition the government pays for your
transition really yeah because of
insurance or legal to be gay so there
have been people who transition not
because they're trans there's a
documentary made about it a couple of
years ago what's it called we don't have
Wi-Fi today our Wi-Fi is down but we are
going to hope I'm not thanking this up
no sort of fever dream I had I think my
transness was actually a lot easier for
my family than my queerness I identified
as queer my sexuality was queer first
because the church had already had years
and years and years of hate built up
against queer folks so they were able to
identify that as something that would
take down the village I always see that
if someone is being hated in a community
it's because people are afraid that that
person is going to be a danger to the
community
that's my compassionate lens and so
there was this idea that they already
knew that that was a sin and so they
they had the language to speak out
against that but the transit Stoke
everyone by surprise and then once I
started having a more conforming binary
feminine look it became a bit easier for
them because there was nothing the
church didn't have anything to say about
transness at that time now they do yeah
right right Wow their hate caught up Wow
my family not my family my family
accepting but the church in general hmm
and then so could you just for people
listening that are younger that are sort
of trying to figure out what's going on
what was your journey like just in terms
of oh this is what I am oh wait no this
is what I am and then this is what I am
I know I've heard you talk about seeing
Roux at a young age and oh yeah I saw
RuPaul in like 1994 when the supermodel
came out and my cousin called me was
that girl you got to come over to me
moth and watch this video if we didn't
have empty to get our place on the farm
so I went over to me moss and I waited
by the television for that music video
came on and she's like that used to be a
man and I was fascinated I thought
RuPaul was trans I didn't know what
RuPaul was it just gave me enough
permission
it gave me enough space to play a little
bit with gender in my young mind and I
was able to realize that okay there are
more possibilities out there than the
ones I've been given and so just your
point about you know some that's being a
mirror it's just like the more you can
see the more you can start figure out
what's going on or see yourself
reflected yeah can you and unless this
makes you uncomfortable you don't want
to like what are some things that the
average person just should not say to a
trans person but just don't start
talking about gender out of nowhere
really exhausting trust me trans people
think of exactly just just don't bring
it up it's really we think about it a
lot we've done a lot of work on it just
assume that we've done a lot of work
also just assume that we're smarter than
you like that's really helpful because
if you know if I look this damn good I
figured something out and just know that
maybe well I've done a little bit more
work on gender than then maybe you have
yeah so um you don't need to really want
to get there brownie points they want to
check that ego box they want to be like
hey I watched pose me can I write it I
know you know I mean it's it's nice to
hear things and it's nice to hear people
come come along and for people to say oh
I didn't know this and
I understand a little bit better of
course that's encouraging I'm just a
human being about things right I don't
know yes I think so but I I think that
um so many people are like actually kind
of eager to really get it right and in
so doing they're sort of exhausting the
very people that they're trying to
respect like so what's your pronoun tell
me everything I need now you to tutor me
for 20 minutes because I'm so
progressive watch four seasons of
transparent and it seasons oppose
everything I want to say about gender I
put on to those shows and can you just
chime in a little bit about you know of
in Hollywood right now not that we're
gonna talk too much about Hollywood but
just that in why we need more
transgender actors playing transgender
roles
well besides its besides it's the right
thing to do for accuracy I mean it's
important to acknowledge that the talent
is out there that there are trans folks
who have talent which was shocking five
years ago when I was going to meeting
after meeting said well we just can't
find any trans talent I'm just like well
you're not looking there's a lot of
trans talent um maybe not all trans
folks have the same access and privilege
assist folks to having an agent or to
having a team that's putting their name
out there but you have to look a little
harder to find trans challenge I think
people have just been afraid of us
slaying the red carpet for all these
years by the way not no not untrue you
just fucked up the bell curve if you
know anything it's like I've noticed
their offense trans folks started
appearing on red carpets like everyone
it's so true how dare you know so we're
just trying to you know Jim how do you
basically meet women you know it's
really it's it's usually they'll reach
out it's sometimes after a show but a
lot of times I get contacted on whether
it's Instagram or social media I mean
people who are aware of me will just
kind of reach out I mean let's be I'm
never gonna go out and it's never gonna
be like a physical thing would they lick
off this guy you know it's always got to
be something they've seen me say that
it's always a mental connection first
and then the physical they just kind of
accept all right there it is what it is
this is what we're working with doing
that I think you're hot
well that you're very sweet but I'm
really not it's uh it's one of that but
it's kind of hard to meet people because
where do you go I mean I'm working every
day you know I've gone on any dating
apps I was I was on all of them Riya I
think I was 100 right all for 278 Riya
is like the it's like the Soho House
update that's exactly right it's right
tinder for pompous assholes and
photographers it's like no it's like
it's a elite dating app or you have to
get accepted right and you also have to
be a photographer from New Zealand so
you have to wear man bonds be a creative
traction and ya know it's so true
it's um but I feel like it's very
curated yeah I'm on Riya yeah making fun
Araya and we're all on it I did so badly
I'd write it so badly yeah really a real
bomb yes bomb done right I remember I
was on it you the thing that's different
about is number one you add like a song
yeah with like a montage of your photos
your song is Tori Amos
hello mr. zebra mr. zebra what a great
panel I was gonna say caught a light
sneeze my mistake Little Earthquakes
maybe even but no mine was a blood
orange song I don't know why I just love
blood honest at the time yet if somebody
didn't know blood orange that was like a
red flag for me I had a bunch of photos
on but I remember you go through and you
see these like random like cryptic ones
like there was like the Damien her skull
was a picture and it ended up being John
Cusack calling you out John don't
remember see Matt didn't lots of like
big celebrities were on there for a
while yeah like didn't Sharon Stone have
to get her put back on one of them
people thought she was a fraud they did
but I wasn't her oh I thought it was
either tinder or that one but they
thought like it wasn't really her
I was on there that's right I was I
don't know if that him marketing oh my
it was a hinge I don't know but I was on
I was on Raya and I had like two people
send me resumes and it hurt my feelings
it was too tomorrow yeah a lot of like
people hustling yeah I mean being a
writer going from being a trans person
who was really struggling um employment
in the arts to being a Hollywood
producer and writer has really changed
my dating life where suddenly everyone
has a script and it do you find that
that's um does that scare you because I
find a lot of times people will try to
get close to me or try to I have not had
a I mean I've been in relationships that
I haven't trusted anyone in six years
yeah you know and it's it's tricky
because people don't call that person
you dated a Starfucker and I'm like does
that mean I'm a star yeah no one's ever
accused a woman oh fuck you being a star
fucker ever it's complicated you know
but um Riya Rhys tricky because it's a
lot of like models and photographer yeah
and I'm always like did they have such a
hard time meeting each other before this
right right so did you go to any dates
on there no I got stood up when I was
out here oh oh it was a good one too
really yes she was so beautiful and I
probably know her no there's not have
any trans women on there and even on
tinder it's annoying because you can put
the option but it should just be a third
optional you should be able to seek
somebody but it was very hard to search
been even know this for shoes she was
not trans but I was going to a party of
Maria Menounos his house cuz my my
co-host knew her table know my calls do
her very well but she was an actress
Ella called this will be great but I
wasn't gonna tell her where I was going
because I'm like I know she'll go just
to go to Maria's place and so I didn't
tell her and she stood me up and I just
were you going I'll meet you there
and she didn't I never I never told her
whose house was and she just never
showed up so I got completely stood up I
feel like you dodged a major bullet no I
know but what kind of an asshole goes to
a party at Maria Menounos his house and
as an actress stand them up like you you
just can't do worse than that in LA I'm
fuck
can't do worse what's your first date
move what's a good first date I go out
to eat I mean I like to talk to somebody
and then that's not me thinking that
right state we're getting dinner on a
four always always always dinner oh I'm
too weird sex like in the sense I'm not
comfortable sexually enough to take
somebody home and try to fuck them
unless I've never done it but again
maybe as you get old they just like you
know how many dates so you try to sleep
with someone it depends on me on that
person there's no number there's no and
again I'm not against it on the first
date but it's I usually just go out to
eat you get to know somebody and just
see if you like them or go out for
coffee
I really just sit down and talk to
somebody and see if I have any
connection with them because again when
you've done all the things physically
you want to try in your life it's like
after a while and I just want to find
people you like yeah you feel like
you've checked every box you've tried it
yeah you've tried this you've tried that
if it's somebody have a connection with
and I don't have to be in love but I
mean it is somebody I would like to at
least like don't in so many of my dates
in the last few years have literally
just been one or two times to dinner and
then maybe it doesn't go anywhere and we
don't see each other yeah like there's
no like oh let's just like give each
other six months of each other's life
for no reason yeah yeah it's not like
kind of no one to call it yeah I'm
comfortable call what's the longest
relationship you've been in three years
maybe ah three years but that's been a
long time yeah a long time yeah you max
it by best friend I mean she lives out
here so I see her whatever out here yeah
but yeah I'm not done very good
relationships I'm just not yeah probably
and it's also running around and doing
gigs yeah yeah and also this this this
fear of aging like I'm afraid of being
old I'm 51 and I'm afraid that if I
settle down with somebody okay now that
do other doors close behind me and this
is the rest of your life fucking scares
me was that person trans the three-year
relation no she was not okay because I
consider it if three years in trans
relationships that's like 30 years yeah
yeah is this relation yeah it's just
like things there's a lot that we bring
to the table I feel like when you're a
trans person and a trans amorous person
meet not with every person but things
there's it's like finally like someone
who fucking gets me and finally I'm
funny feeling seen
and so um or maybe it's just because I'm
codependent um but I just move really
fast in relations yeah you do yeah yeah
I I do sometimes to code you want that I
want it to be here like I used I've done
that like I'm in love but it's a
dopamine drip it's not real just me
looking for the next drug yeah a cup in
your life it's like let me fall in love
with you as fast as I can before I get
to know you because then I'd have to
leave no I don't I don't fall in love
with you because I don't like you we
just the faster we move the faster we'll
just sort of entrench or I know anything
about your character you know that
you're incompatible right away I want to
fall in love with you before I have a
chance of Google you right have you
never googled someone before a date no I
definitely have I always do okay always
always doing okay but my I always have a
rush to fall in love with someone before
I know their character right for sure so
like let's just make sure we're
chemically dependent before we say know
anything about so that it can make the
detangling you know difficult
we talk a lot about this show about red
flags what are some red flags red flag
you have basically given me a list of my
red flag in the past she's handed me a
list of men I can't date and you're so
spot on actually I still have that list
you actually helped me make that list we
did a red flag list once cuz I was just
failing I'm obsessed with red flags
because for me I am such an addict like
when I get caught up with the oxytocin
and the dopamine I just can't see I
totally go blind and I have to go
is he married yes okay I have to turn
around like I have to have a list there
because I get so sort of delusional yeah
just go blind I like red flags do they
tell me which direction to head in right
through a red flag I plow through a red
flag I love them they're so juicy
because you know it's just gonna be so
much drama I mean that's the thing is
that I I now I'm not the person that's
like I hate drama I love it
I know I love it put it in my fucking
chains I live for it like I just I I
love drama I love the adrenaline turns
into dopamine I know
adrenaline is my primary drug and as
writers you know that you're gonna make
money from it
oh my god I'm gonna put that down and
people are gonna cry when they watch
that and I'm gonna know more yes yes but
I think just knowing that about yourself
knowing that adrenaline is where I
thrive drama is what is sort of like my
default what I'm magnetically attracted
to it's just like a daily trying to kind
of like manage that yeah you know but
for me red charm is a red flag
I know I know no charm is a red flag
because it's a defense mechanism that
you developed as a kid you know so the
more charming someone is the more I got
to just like get away from them that's a
big one for me moving fast is a big one
for me hmm
not communicating every day is a red
flag for me yeah I kind of like not
communicating every time but some kind
of communication anything really hmm I
like if couple days go by really you do
at first because then like oh they have
a life and they're busy with their
career so you think that if someone
communicates with you every day that's
kind of addict a behavior yeah not every
day but like if it's throughout the day
times a day until you've established and
let's have a thing of like hey exactly
let's connect every day and we're -
until you're together yeah exactly
what's your perfect first date my
perfect first date um well obviously
somewhere in black like yeah I'm gonna
lower the bar here for everyone in
public is the only thing I really
that's a pretty easy first there has to
be coffee within 500 feet to see me
dreaming and getting excited about my
dream day I like I like a meal as well I
have to have dinner because if it's just
a coffee then I know they're broke and
not willing to invest
Lola is a modern approach to feminine
care a female founded company offering a
line of organic cotton tampons pads
liners and all-natural cleansing wipes
that Benton sometimes uses to remove
makeup but they're actually feminine
products
I love Lola 100% natural if you're
putting something inside your body you
don't want to be full of chemicals and
fragrances and shady-ass right random
poisons and stuff and all the thinman
products that I made myself who knew
what was in them I was just whatever I
could find litter
ya know cleansing agents no added
chemicals no dyes no nonsense 100%
organic product no chemicals fragrances
synthetics or dyes I'm gonna keep
yelling this at you buy this so much
better for you so much better for the
environment safe to put anywhere in your
body biodegradable all-natural
individually packaged and you can
customize it based on your flow what you
need so you don't have like 50 extra
tampons lying around in your purse like
a crazy person thirty percent off your
first month subscription visit my Lola
comm enter Whitney when you subscribe my
Lola comm Raffi's is already my favorite
company because in the ad copy they sent
they wrote in big red letters no
profanity triggers I was not planning on
being profane I love this company
unless I was gonna curse to be like I
love this company so effing much maybe
that's it there but not today not today
I'm not gonna use that I'm gonna say so
freaking much I love this company
they make stylish shoes for women and
girls out of recycled plastic water
bottles in their continuous there it's
genius and you got me you picked him out
for me and I know them got you some high
tops and some nice businesswoman loafers
some they were my flat well flats so
that I could do my Audrey Hepburn thing
I could walk in and so people think I'm
classy all of a sudden and they're
machine washable people respect me the
fact that you could just put these in
the washing machine when they're dirty
this is such a game-changer yeah you go
from the office to see your horse and
let me wash them right up yeah I can
step in crap oh I get why they were
worried about profanity that's about to
occurs again I can put them in the
washing machine and clean them right up
I hate it when I'm wearing
new shoes and I'm worried about getting
them dirty oh yeah it's so annoying it's
insane
why did it take so long to figure this
out they are made from again repurposed
plastic water bottles Rafi's has
diverted over 35 million water bottles
from landfills and you feel good about
yourself conscious fashion check out all
the amazing styles available right now
Rafi's calm / Whitney rod these calm are
oth YS calm / Whitney get your new
favorite flats comfort style
sustainability these are the shoes
you've been waiting for
head to Rafi's calm / Whitney where do
we land on sending naked pictures where
are we on this are we doing it are we
not doing it for the person I like
getting them if the person wants me most
most women don't want to see your ding
it's just not the way it works
men are much more but if somebody wants
when I would but I would like to get one
sure my face is never in them know by
her request it depends on how good I
look like if this you know if if this
ever gets out than you I'm fine yeah oh
I got it we just go I'm gonna if this
goes out I will I would stand by this
yeah totally essentially I've never
taken a picture of my crotch ever you
have in life never and never ever well
let's play a healthy way to be - to be
not genital obsessed that's like that's
a healthy way too big ya know I think so
too I think it's um I had a like a nude
get out like get leaked and I was so
annoyed because it wasn't one that I
took it wasn't one I was like I've so
many good ones in here like the one bad
one is the one that got leaked out one
that like I accidentally took but I
think we kind of have to act as if all
of our photos are because I feel like
that is kind of the case for sure right
Jim I wanna talk a little bit about
what's going on with you you're touring
and you just have another special yeah
it's called the degenerate season to him
the first episode Netflix I'm happy I
said no to it at first like in a used
and I was so happy I did it like my ego
almost fucked me up I'm so happy why
because it was a lot of comments someone
show it was yeah I'm like we're all in
the same night no like no yeah it's you
of your episodes it's not you're not
doing this I thought evening The Improv
like no no no and uh it's play my
favorite 20 minutes that I've shot and
I'm not just saying that because it's
recent like I'm fucking really happy
with
does it come out it's on now it just
came out and I get so that and the
Irishman had a small part in that those
the two things on wrinkles and the Irish
friend if fucking like lit me up when I
saw that the fact that it made it in is
a miracle like I thought like there's no
way he cut down from four to three and a
half there's no way I'm staying in but I
want to stay here and did you I mean Don
Rickles obviously such a fucking I mean
led you did that trip you up to have to
play down recalled yeah I've been
compared to my whole career excites the
face shape or there's something about
the kid I don't know what it is eyebrows
tiny bit yeah it is something because
people have always said it so they
offered it to me I didn't have to
audition there Scorsese like watch stuff
I did he goes yeah this guy can do it so
I wanna they want to meet with me so I
went and met with him in his office in
Brooklyn and I sat down talked for 10
minutes no audition no read and he's a
guy great let me see the makeup and how
they're doing it and we did it and I had
the dialogue and I wound up making it in
it was it was really surreal how did you
navigate like I'm not gonna do an
impression but I'm also need to do Don
Rickles
I went to Bob Krakow as an acting coach
you know just for a couple of words for
a couple of like regional dialect things
but I didn't want to do a full-on
impression I've watched Rickles enough
so I just kind of got a lot of stuff
from hello dummy and I had the script
and I wound up doing just because they
asked me Scorsese is weary he's been our
just go up there and start to and like I
had to just go up and just do Don
Rickles shit like with Pacino and De
Niro and Pesci to the audience and they
knew him so it was really weird to do it
in front of the nightmare because three
guys who knew him so well so that was
kind of the weird part about it but it
went really well and the fact that they
fucking left it in I mean I really
thought he had cut until the night
before yeah I'm very happy and then this
last DeGeneres that you talked about
depression
yeah yeah but every comedians depressed
too you know I've talked about it a lot
I talk about the depression
Ted Bundy but yeah I mean we all go
through that suicidal ascent Bundy
depressed no he should have been he's
actually no I almost admire his ability
to overlook the obvious in fucking
prison yeah like what was that guy
200 milligram no concept of compunction
at all and yeah and you talked about
before without you you sorta talked
about this last one in a way that just
made me laugh so fuckin hard you know
you cuz it is a tricky thing because you
never want the audience feel sorry for
no and you never want to feel like
you're like because you know there is
this mom where everyone's talking about
mental health which is a great thing
mental wealth but it's also just heard
of like oh god I've heard a lot of
depression jokes at this point it's
almost like the new airplane humor yeah
and it's you fucking it was so funny and
just so incisive and um you know thank
you because it's weird it's like I just
if you're standing up there and you're
telling the audience like folks I have
pain we all do idiots it's just got to
come from the same place for everything
else like there's been times where I've
been standing and I'm gonna jump in
front of a train and I'm not gonna do it
but there's a line I talked about with
somebody getting a dragging minguk's I
interviewed a woman who had her jumping
off a train and she got her leg and I
think her arm cut off so it's like you
think of that shit when you want to do
it see if you come up and you just talk
about it honestly I'm not looking for an
emotional impact from anybody in the
audience I'm not looking to change
anybody's you know it's like yeah this
is what I've thought of sure I've
thought alone my brains out but I'm
scared because I'm afraid I won't it
won't work and people just believe that
just maybe I'm sorry cuz that is it it's
like I'm afraid I'll survive yeah trying
to kill myself
yeah and that is the fear because you're
never in better shape so people I love
it even within thinking about killing
yourself like my self-esteem is so low I
know I'm gonna blow it yeah yeah I can't
even kill myself that's how stupid I am
yeah that's the fear is that I would be
in worse shape or I'll be more damaged
right so yeah it's just talking about it
the same way you talk about everything
yell I don't like because people really
responded to the suicide stuff but I
don't like making it like it's this it's
this thing that needs to be talked about
because again my pain is no different
than anybody else is it's no more
fucking valid it's no deeper it's no
more interesting just another asshole
who fucking hates himself on some level
welcome to the club and people can
relate to that and I do think and look
and and because everyone's not everyone
but a lot of people are feeling like
they can be more vulnerable and talk
about their weaknesses and pain but like
I comedians like it is our job to be
funny yes this is what we do we write
jokes like if it ends up moving the
needle great but it is my job ultimately
the end
the day to make you laugh I'm not an
expert I'm not a scientist I'm not a
therapist I'm not a psychiatrist and I
think some politician I'm really just
trying to do what my skill set is that's
exactly and the job is not like whether
to matter what you're talking about
the last thing you want is a comic after
you say something is yeah I don't want
your pity I want a huge laugh oh this
isn't a TED talk no not at all like I
just talked about hanging myself yeah
let's have a laugh that's what you want
something you want a big pop of a lab
and there's a comic if you're not going
for a big laugh if you're going for an
applause break yes you're after it's an
epidemic it's embarrassing and your
virtue signally and it's just kind of
stopped yes I'm not trying to get your
pity I'm not trying to get your sympathy
I'm not I'm not trying to get your vote
like I'm I think it's harder than ever
to kind of stay in your lane because
there is this sort of thing every now
and then we're like wait a second should
I like have a message and it's like
that's not what I'm qualified to do
people get sent if you're being honest
your message is whatever you're telling
the truth about a little consents that
yeah yeah and like let me let the
experts do the talking you know and then
I'm gonna try to make you guys laugh
yeah I just have to ask because a lot of
people ask me about is it getting harder
to do comedy do you feel like there's
stuff that's off-limits I think you are
a comedian who can pretty much talk
about fucking anything and make it funny
you have to you know strikes like you
know thirty years in you just learn how
where to structure and where to this has
to be a good joke yeah or the attempt at
the joke has to be obvious because a
Patrice had a great point about a good
and bad jokes are born from the same
place like that birthed from the same
place so it's like a good joke a bad
joke is subjective you just gotta be
trying to be funny yeah that's all I
mean we all miss Timmy funny yeah we all
swing and miss fucking horribly you'll
do I was watching you last night the
Jeffrey Epstein joke bombing I mean it
wasn't bombing but I love that you kind
of put up jokes when they bomb the
beauty of I love jokes when they bond
it's so uncomfortable
it's what we do I love posting it
because I think a lot of people assume
that a convenient your level just never
bombs yeah you know and there are times
when you'll do a great joke and you'll
just like this isn't my fault this is
your fault it's just this joke is gonna
kill in like two weeks I'm obsessed with
just the timing of
jokl kill and kind of when it won't like
I've been doing um I was doing this joke
about like the NFL and it was like
killing and then it just started bombing
out of nowhere cuz I think someone got
hurt and then it started killing again
you know it's just such a delicate
balance now with how much news is out
there and when people get sensitive yeah
sometimes it's just a way I it's hard to
do like what you're gonna talk about
something horrible and you know it's
gonna be horrible you try to paint them
into a corner like you try to try to cut
their exits off yeah bite but you start
chopping at certain things because you
know where you're going and then all of
a sudden they've sealed themselves in so
they're kind of there with you and
they're stuck so they have to go with
you right if you leave that fucking
backdoor open a lot of times the
audience will yeah kind of let
themselves back out of it yeah sometimes
it's just how you set it up you got to
paint them into a corner in a way before
you really hit them with whatever you
want to get to but I love watching those
videos because it really is a
masterclass in stand up because the
greats don't panic and they don't rush
so watching watching you you said tell
me about the Lolita Express right and it
got a little quiet and it's almost like
you slow down yeah instead of speed up
when a lot of people's instinct is to
speed up into panic and to switch to
another topic and you just sit in that
discomfort and it's just it's such a
it's so fun to watch yeah cause it's
weird it's almost like you know that
it's not going where you want to go but
they don't necessarily know that so
you're just trying to go this is exactly
how I meant this yes right every
comedian wants 40 seconds of silence
sometimes you acknowledge it too though
it's fun to acknowledge it yeah they
sense it a lot of times they see you're
bombing so say this is fucking bonding
you have to they kind of like the idea
it's like a it's a human nature exercise
really it's like some alpha shit it's
like it really is but comes about
courage you know it just becomes about
like how long can I just sit in this
uncomfortable space and then it becomes
like performance art for me I think the
audience wants to trust the person
that's on the stage that they're in a
safe space and if they see that person
panicking then they know that they're no
longer safe or they're just in charge
yeah they're in charge yeah yes you
don't need them they come around to you
if they can sense that you're
particularly needy they go away it's
like anything else it's you know it's
just you're attracted they tend to be
attracted by the fact
you're confident enough what you're
saying to not need them yeah no we do
need them and that it is this really
fine line of I don't give a fuck about
your approval but I am here for your
approval yeah you know it's just like a
wild thing how you have to be able to
turn that on and off and even your body
I'm just obsessed with you know
comedians even body language when you're
quiet you're not leaning forward you're
standing straight up because two inches
forward is needy yeah I need your
approval I need something from you and
then they kind of lean out a little bit
and then you lose them you know I think
it's just it's just taking me so long to
kind of understand just what's going on
when you're not even talking as a
community I'll be at the cellar so sorry
I'll be at the cellar sometimes it's not
going well and there's an old stage and
you can hear the creaking and I'll be
standing on the stand and I can hear the
creaking and I'm like oh like they must
be able to hear that so small rooms they
must go to hear that into that to the
room like wow that's fucking quiet I
just love it so much because to me I
love watching how comedy changes and
what what bravery is and how it changes
and to me like that's just the most
gangster shit for you to be onstage just
like sitting there letting something
kind of bomb and then regroup well you
don't have learn lead Colin Colin Quinn
is I think Colin is the best comic
working because Colin will do he's got a
new fucking hour it's like it really
makes sure what fucking throw yourself
in front of a bus but Colin never does
the audience's emotional work for them
this is why he's so great cuz he'll do
his bit if it bombs he doesn't sit there
and lash out at them he'll acknowledge
it but he doesn't blame them even though
he might internally and when he's doing
a bit that you know he feels something
about he's not acting angry like he
doesn't do their work for that's really
really that he's there's no one more
collected onstage and Colin because no
matter what's happening he just he
remains the same like he doesn't fucking
panic never pal
never gay he never delivers lazy he
never takes the easy way to get to it I
think Colin is the best guy onstage
there's also no fat none no fat the way
that he writes there's just not one
where it's like almost Shakespearean
that every word matters yeah you know
there's no sloppiness and I think
there's this there is comedies changing
a little bit it's becoming more
conversational which is cool in some
ways but there's other ways where like
you don't need that word you don't need
that word like he's surgical yeah in the
way that he does it and I just I love
watching great writers yeah his last one
I think he made a really
in case about how America should
basically break into two countries a
blue say yeah it was so fucking good
wasn't on CNN yes that's when you know
you're a great comedian with the area
specialist on CNN yeah Netflix i think
ii went back on netflix uh but he's got
a new hour now i just saw it and it's
like I understand why people on
Instagram don't like creepy and
Instagram because you're seeing your
friends do all this amazing the shit I'm
a chimpanzee I'm a fuckin chimpanzee in
this business but my do it like you know
you watch guys like that you're like he
just he's works it out every week he's
working I was hour working on his hours
fucking some machine and then what is
your relationship to social media it's
where I get all my validation my
relationship is I that's yeah period
yeah but like just such an incredible
tool to be able to reach people that you
normally absolutely well I've learned
that if I have something to say I'm not
going to put it on social media I'm
gonna put it in my work oh because I'm
not gonna give that shit out for free oh
why am I gonna give that out for free so
my social media is kind of bland and
just pictures of me um looking amazing
and if you want to know what I have to
say go to my work I really I think
that's why I I didn't end up going into
comedy because I I am too scared to have
that confrontation with the audience I
can do it in music music is so planned
to how and you control the sound and you
control the space with music exactly and
I need to have revisions of what I'm
going to say especially in these times I
feel like it's it's a lot safer for me
to revise and edit in a small room and
then put that out into the world and if
I'm going to put something on Twitter
then it's just I'm not gonna have
control of the space yes and I need to
have control of that space so I actually
don't enjoy social media for I'm getting
my voice out I just like it for
validation do you feel like because you
become so famous and you know well I
just mean I mean certainly an authority
in my letters I have a voice yes in a
microphone and you know does that come
with like III like I don't like being
held up as like a
model or someone to look because like
I'm like I'm still flawed and I'm still
gonna make mistakes like do you feel
pressure to be perfect all the time say
the right thing from your community well
transparent I was the first trans person
ever to be hired in a writers room and I
was the only trans person in a writers
room at that time and so there was a
spotlight on every word that I said so I
thank God I'm very close to my community
and I make sure I bounce the pitches off
of people outside of writers rooms as
well to say you know is this what we
need to talk about right now is this
where we're going with the movement is
this how we need to educate people so
yeah there's an incredible amount of
pressure less now hmm I feel like I'm
terrible at this no no really good I'm
like working on getting better at it but
I guess like yeah I mean you've been
doing this for so long
no but there's tons make it yeah you
can't overthink it you just talk and you
know I mean there's three people much of
the through sat here looking at each
other I mean we all talk so I mean we'll
figure it out it was texting each other
I'm just like that's gonna mean trouble
shit shit I said that that could be
taken out of knife I've had that thought
five times in the t-bird conversation oh
yeah how am I gonna get in trouble
talking about this but here's the good
news about and this is why podcasting it
took me so long to do this is that you
don't you get to clarify your comments
you get to go like well or this and you
get to sort of have like I would never
have this conversation in a short-form
way sure you know
yeah there's no getting in trouble I
mean we're discussing something and if
people don't like it and they want
because the idea the trouble is the
anger around these things a lot of times
is not real it's just again people don't
acknowledge how much they love the
pile-on yeah it's just like it's making
me realize like when people come at me
on social media with any kind of like
anger and stuff and I now I'm just able
to go like oh you're in pain you're sad
you're just sad that's okay you're sad
and this is how we're wired you're a lot
nicer than me I always go look at you
aren't you shitty come and get me like
that you're shitty I don't know I I mean
Opie and Anthony people though I just
feel like that's those talking shit is
kind of how they show love I mean in a
lot of ways it is yeah there's a kind of
a brutality in the language and the way
you communicate and stuff but then
there's there's another crop of people
who are coming after you trying to nail
you it's because the drug is get you I
wish people just acknowledged how good
that it feels but they don't want to
acknowledge it such a great place they
just self-righteous indignation feels
so guns sure Oh superiority Oh give it
to me
yeah that's such a great point Jim and I
don't think enough people point that out
how good it feels to watch someone get
canceled and it's also to be a part of
it because everybody feels emasculated
nothing we have no power we can't
control everything everything's beyond
our control when you pile on somebody
and they get fired holy fuck I help move
the needle I did something I'm a part of
something that actually has a tangible
result and I think that there's a
ephemeral kind of well they I'm safe
Yeah right for now for now persons on
fire I'm not I'm fine you know there's
this like a little bit of invincibility
around okay they're dealing with that
person I must be safe at least yeah now
you know with the beauty is it's a
circle people are firing each other in a
circle they think that they're lined up
in there safe but you're not you're all
standing in a circle you're just
shooting next in the next it's like the
girlfriend that always talks shit about
all the girl your girlfriends you're
like oh she leaves here she just goes
and does the same thing about me yeah
you know god I feel like I don't know
what what do you think should have
happen with Shane jealous you think you
should have kept the job yeah I mean
businesses have reasons for getting rid
of people but I think that Shane when I
watched the yay system harsh shit but
when I saw him doing this thing where he
was like obviously in a character doing
the this Asian joke and I don't remember
the joke but he was doing it kind of
like a it was obvious obvious to be it
was a character no I don't think he
should have been fired no I don't think
people can object to one but look at
that look what we tolerate in show
business yeah yeah no it's great I mean
the amount of fucking people that have
drug arrests the amount of people who
have done the best enrollment fucking
Polanski Gibson has 14 movies in
productions crazy
Roman Polanski is being considered for
an Oscar in France yeah so I mean come
on who we kick now we're selective like
all of a sudden Shane said some dumb
shit yeah yeah he said some - okay fine
that was tasteless that was said in poor
taste absolutely should not have been
fired I'm sick and tired of people being
canceled for dumb little things they say
or even major things they say I mean
there's zero forgiveness in the culture
and there's zero context in the culture
yeah we have no forgiveness yeah we also
we think Twitter is so much bigger than
it is 22 percent of people on Twitter of
that 2 percent generate 80% of the
comments Wow and we're like everyone's
saying so 2 percent of 22 percent yes
generate 80% of the comments what number
would that be with 2 bit just like psych
I don't know the fact that I got through
that is a fucking miracle um what else
the Irishman the degenerates yeah go
touring uh yeah Jim Norton Connor I got
a whole bunch of cities on sale if you
want to come see me also you know a
person is my favorite it's you two
humiliated me the idea of thinking about
- I forgot he exists didn't do you don't
do it anymore I do it once a week for a
podcast but it's like literally blacking
out and I forget it exists this is my
favorite fucking thing ever Jim does
this I'm sorry okay do not shaming him
no it's okay I should be shamed for no
it's my favorite shit ever it's this
character it's humiliating how did that
go where did that come about I would do
it in my private life with girlfriends
and I would do it to embarrass them and
it made them so angry I did it one time
and I was dating a girl and she actually
dug her fingernails into my face and I
went oh wow that's a visceral something
there and on the radio people hated it
it really is yeah so the fact that it
got a reaction and it was very freeing
and fun so I have a podcast I do every
Sunday it comes out and it's a very
acquired taste I just love your videos
what is uh what's the one with chicken
where's my chicken I don't know you were
like you're like ordering something and
you're like I'm looking for my chicken
oh that was oh my god that was Instagram
video from a year ago I have like a
couple friends we do it all the time or
like where's my chicken it's like I was
I was very skinny then - I put my soup
pants on they don't fit I forgot my mom
wearing sweatpants I forgot my pants I
having some award show tomorrow and I
have a fucking pair of I've never get
asked to do a worse show this why I'm
doing it and I have a pair of pants that
won't fit like I can't stop fucking
eating what is this it's just some art
director I'm I'm not discounting if it's
not televised no I know but do you feel
like you want like when Hollywood calls
you're like I gotta do it every time I
get like can you present it as a word
show I'm like
yeah I figured I wanted to do it I
wanted to come out for a couple of other
things too so it actually just worked
out but yeah it's not a televised thing
but I just I put my suit pants on last
night for something else and I'm like I
am a fucking disgusting eating slob I
can't stop no I have good eyesight I
don't think a man does a man ever answer
yes to that question I don't think no I
think it's accurate I know when I look
good like in that video you made me
think all I'm thinking of is I would sit
on my counter
my legs were crossed I was goofing
around and I was very skinny too skinny
almost like I look back at some of those
photos of myself and I are fighting yeah
but a lot of it was real depression I
looked unhealthy like it was a weight
loss that didn't look like it was a
healthy it was doing just not eating I
was on Nile or eating very minimally so
it just didn't it didn't look or feel
healthy a few pounds heavier than that
would have been great but now I'm gonna
point out where I can't wear my suit
pants but do you take care of yourself
yeah I mean to assert very pretty
healthy but you know I just ate too much
recently that's it
don't eat so much yeah very simple say
no what a treat I know I have to get you
out of here at some point I just want to
keep talking forever what's long as
podcast you've ever done do I'm gonna
guess it was I've done Joe show a bunch
so I'm gonna guess it might be Rogen for
three hours that probably it's just so
comfortable I mean now you can just long
for me I have to pee so fucking bad I at
least once every episode I do it you go
out and pee Oh sucky I can't
Instagram our Lady Jaye just the letter
J and you can send me a message if you
like as well if you're curious about the
whole trans amory Duccio do you check
your DMS I go through maybe once a week
into the junk is that the junk came out
like no it's the request the request oh
yes you have like official encounters
yeah yeah so I don't get it what's the
best way and I scroll through and and
then what's a good opener for you well
it's just so many little picture this
big looks cute enough
I might open it but what is like a like
oh yeah I'm gonna respond to this person
like what's a good opening message
um hey ma is not a good one look at that
Allah hey mom that's a New York thing
though I think that's kind of a New York
thing I don't know I've never said I was
telling me I was like hey I wouldn't say
that's my mother terrible things
so hey Maz Noga hema or like a career
compliment I don't like either cuz then
you know they know you or they're trying
to get something because then if I
respond to that then it's like when our
auditions or when is this and then I
send them the casting notice and did
that whole thing you know but um I don't
know I haven't I guess I haven't really
gotten a good message cuz I have never
met a boyfriend on Instagram before
never no never the last guy I was in a
relationship what we'd matched on tinder
but had also followed each other and
Instagram before that so that I don't
know if that can overlap the kind of a
history yeah but we had but we had to
know that we were attracted to each
other on tinder first before there was
any flirtation on Instagram and then one
thing I want to ask you before I let you
go cuz I know you have to UM is what is
this machine you're sleeping with sleep
apnea machine I don't use it now because
I have to get sinus surgery but I have a
mouth guard I need to get sinus surgery
so I can use the apnea machine because
I've apnea jo koy is all over reason
you're gonna fucking die I'm like I know
he's got me at the math yeah see
everyone's on that now right yeah it's
like tubes it's fucking crazy yeah yeah
cuz it was so part of me that said look
I'm not unfuckable enough what can I
really do to add to this disaster how
about a mask that's what I need a mask
on my face it's fucking crazy it's like
actually I would be attracted to that
some of the profiles are that audio
fixation thing yeah he'll have like
latest mass cover your face scare me a
little bit
I'm you can die doing that there's guys
who would be like into being donned
we're like a saran wrap over the Fae
that that's was not what happened to
David Carradine hanging himself I think
he's probably be auto-erotic or
Roenick appreciation I think well you
might even depress I don't know I think
he was he dressed at the time to lien
thigh-highs or is that a rumor I thought
he was dressed so it might have been
like an autoerotic asphyxiation I think
we didn't even get into this part of the
conversation we could stay here for
another trans attractiveness and thus
abdominus there's a lot of overlap when
you say I don't know subdominant like a
lot of men who want to be a lot of
manners that I have met that are
attracted to me maybe because I'm six
foot one and very powerful they enjoy
being dominated as well and then is that
something that it just kind of goes
without saying it comes up later is that
like a conversation it usually comes up
because they want to know about my
genitals
early when that happens okay because
they want to know if it's possible
uh-huh and then and then I realize if it
comes up too early that's like obviously
like a red flag right that I do pay
attention yeah but I don't know that
that's a I think there's a lot to
dissect there around trans
attractiveness and and their
relationship to porn as well a lot of
guys discover trans bodies through porn
so that's exactly how I did is that a
hundred percent I was fifteen salka she
was a porn star in the you know it is
1983 and I didn't know what trans why
had never heard of it I didn't know that
it existed and I was watching porn with
my friends and she came on Wow and they
were like oh and I was like oh yeah it
made sense it made sense oh that makes
sense to me I own identity well I think
the thing that's dangerous about that
for trans women is that like imagine
being a sis woman and the only body that
your partner has seen that looks like
yours is from porn so you suddenly feel
all this pressure to behave like right
like someone who's working in porn and
trans bodies are not the same as the
bodies that you see in porn like real
life transparent a lot of trans
performers go off hormones and so things
function a bit differently but there is
like a lot of within trans relationships
there are a lot of men bring baggage
from porn into the relationship that
they project onto the women and I know
this happens in sis relationships as
well
but especially choking us choking it I
mean once in a while yeah but it's like
it's like a it's like they think we want
it we think they want it and no one will
it's just like and then we're acting
it's a it's not even real it's just like
we're gonna do it do it if your dad
don't make me we all become performers
yeah totally and where is the intimacy I
knew that I knew that porn I you know
had kind of taken over every guy's brain
when I was with this guy and he put his
hand in my mouth like like three fingers
in my mouth and just like set it there
and I don't think he even knew what he
was doing he had seen it in something
but he panicked and I didn't understand
what's happening I think I started
laughing because it was just like I
think he thought he was gagging or
staring but I think he it was not
something he really wanted but maybe he
thought a woman wanted it it was just
this like half-assed
sort is the thing yeah it's a lazy
domination of commercial thing where
it's like it just whack Amole at a
certain point you know when you see a
guy you know it's like rebuffering
stream and he's like kind of doing as
many things you can that he's seen from
porn and it all kind of conflates if
it's any consolation men destroy
ourselves with porn to like you know I
see our dicks are Baja yeah horrendous
compared to what's important so it's
like as much as there's expectations on
the partner men we never feel like we we
look at porn or like oh the fuck am i
doing
yeah it also wrecks it on the other and
you get kind of like to sensitize after
a while you do and that's the only bad
part about it like I've really kind of
cut down watching it just because it's
not it doesn't feel like anything yeah
nothing you know you can't feel anything
it's like it's more and more and more
and more I need more and more yes yes
and I can always tell when I'm with
someone like how much porn they watch
based on the amount of intimacy that
we're having and a lot of times if they
just like shut off and they with child
and I'm not the shaming porn at all I
think like porn has a beautiful place in
society but there is a lot that shuts
down in an intimate relationship when
that's how they're learning about trans
bodies and
they have a real trans body in front of
them that doesn't function like a
performer and it's like oh they're so
disappointed I think this would be so
awesome if you had no preconceived also
watching there's this woman named Gail
dines who did a TED talk about what porn
is doing to sort of younger kids which
is like it used to be like when you
wanted to see boobies you know when you
were 10 or 12 you would like go find
your dad's Sears catalog or sure
whatever the fuck I don't even know now
if a kid wants to just a 10 year old boy
wants to just see boobies goes to the
Internet Google's boobies and like choke
porn comes out or fisting and like
that's their introduction they think
that's what sex is you know so it's you
can't see something innocent like boobs
now even if you tried right you know so
it's so extreme the first thing that
they're seeing and she was saying that
porn stars the girls come now and they
call it porn ready like they used to
have to teach porn stars what to do now
they show up they know exactly what sure
it was just like this crazy thing was
like they used to be like porn
instructors who would tell girls what to
do and how to arch her back on all the
stuff and they're like oh they don't
even need to know I do that oh man sir
my Instagram lives check it out that's
fascinating all right so I know you have
to get to Rogan I have to pee so bad
yeah what else am I missing
how many Emmys do you have I don't have
any oniy Emmys I've been nominated I
don't have an actual guys every time I
see I have fucking award no I have two
Peabody's okay what okay that's that's I
don't actually have many trophies
trophies no just bodies on my piano
mm-hmm
just in case they're really heavy I knew
you creepy body I would like to just go
on record what's that you name a
pre-baby body and then I'm gonna be
pretty surgery which is high no like
when I sew I recently read ated someone
I dated before my surgery Oh like last
month how'd that go really well actually
because I was like this person was
attracted to me before ending my
surgeries so maybe they really see me
for who I am and you I mean we're still
friends but yeah we're just not really
that compatible but it was nice it's
nice to see people before and after the
surgeries because like the world does
change and it gets really dark when you
realize how people
are only relying on the exterior to get
to know someone we can go to a really
dark place if you like I love a dark
place that's what we're this is it was
my life we're in a dark place yeah you
know the darkness of humanity be um an
ugly duckling turn into a beautiful flan
and then you'll realize you can never
trust any what the fuck are you doing
your skin Jesus Christ what are you
doing to your skin I do a derma roller I
do got me an I talk about all the way
I'm the derma roller it's like a little
prickly thing because our products
actually aren't even absorbing into our
skin because of all the dead skin cells
on top I stopped doing laser because it
makes your skin thinner what ladies are
you doing the peel but it was like a the
what's the derma flash or something like
that you have no redness anywhere huh I
don't do lasers anymore
because it makes your skin thinner and
you know that like kind of reptile II
shiny look that I had for a while left
that look that it takes the hair off
your face so then you just look a little
too shiny I think so I do the derma
roller and then I do all this other shit
on topic but I got a colostrum a
placenta I got all sorts of shit baby
dicks no I just no money ie
estrogen every day you take estrogen
yeah yeah and then that kind of helps my
skin out as well yeah there are three
things that I'm having done though this
summer that I tell me I'm not wait for
so my chin fell from my surgery I have
an amazing surgeon but sometimes these
things happen yeah where my chin fell so
they're gonna straighten that out and
then they're gonna straighten my nose Oh
like lift this a little bit guys yeah
because this is getting a little trippy
it's really none see I don't know if I
agree with that
that's because I'm wearing makeup to
disguise the true mm-hmm I could how did
we get back to surgery that's not where
you're supposed to go I love you sorry I
love you okay I love you Lady Jaye Noren
you know where to find thank you for
having me it was fun yeah I know you
told me I was on with somebody I had no
idea who is really great it was like the
only day you were here and we were
scheduled I can No thank you for you
squeeze me and I appreciate you sharing
the time with me two things I love you
thank you very much my favorite people I
always had these very awkward
[Music]
[Applause]